yo what's up it's me samuel l jackson i
play a samurai cat in the new animated
theatrical film paws of fury the legend
of hank meow
that means roll it
why do you want to be a samurai
[Music]
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times maybe could use some help
himself but where can i find one
[Music]
get out of here who even made that
it's you don't believe everything you
read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
go get them
get back out there
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it
[Applause]
don't forget to land on your
feet
[Music]
send a tweet to assemble the troops
who knew an evil army could go through
so many beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the mother father cocker spaniel's
going on here
this might take a while